[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
play the people yeah that was intense
yeah this flying King yes that that's
the second part for those who were
following me and Peter's let me
introduce my colleague Elmyra scription
como going here by Al Mira without the
second name yeah we have unpronounceable
second names both of us women partly al
Mira and Miro
will play the people right and those of
you guys in chat who were screaming for
the mirror of taking over the mouse
playing some games it will happen so
this dream will last for couple of hours
first we'll let al Mira show of her
skills and then at some point I'll join
and pretend to be a chess expert now we
let see the real chess expert yeah it's
not so easy also to feel the great Peter
Swedish shoes so I'll try to do my best
I hope this mirror will entertain you
during this hour as much as I can it
also will have a look at the challenges
I don't know yeah and just interrupt a
few questions to ask here before the
before we start actually sir what time
control but typically we try to do like
three minutes onwards so 3 plus 2 5
minutes that that's yeah that's great
tree might be a bit challenging but when
I'll switch the seats maybe I'll try to
do like tree all but yes so 5 0 3 plus 2
it would be an
much purposes proposal and so for those
of you who are asking some questions in
the chat you can probably do this in
English Russian French well some other
languages as well but let's stick to
those from I speak perfect French I'll
we'll be able to identify it's French so
go with the first challenge and this
time no me meaning round will try to
play this and trust so I hope that Peter
has warned the people down so like I'm
really tired ok let's go I'm except it's
the first challenge accepted
and we are playing with black and we've
managed to increase chess like a chess
club's rating by a huge like ok this
math is the challenge and Furman see
guys already complaining oh just shut up
how do you call the opening you're
playing I don't know I'm trying to play
a cylinder but I think my opponent is
trying to trick me
h3 very useful move in the Philidor well
it depends on the move order of course
ok we should be also you do it with c6
yeah we fitted there is a very useful
opening for these games I think because
you're trying to do all the moves
basically you can play like 10 moves
without exactly switching the bridge
exactly my brain is wait a sec but now
you no longer play the Philidor you
played the pier goal the question if 960
are ok yeah we did play 1 960 which Bo
basically Peter played 1 960 because I
have no idea I'm honestly the only thing
I'm thinking when I'm playing in 960
game is
okay know how to trade all the stuff so
I can have like the normal position so
that's well I actually haven't played a
single 960 games in your life in my life
you see I really you definitely should
try it
yeah challenge on Mira on in 960 go oh
my god this is very you know what's your
rating that that's impolite question I
have to yeah but with such a rating
you see if she can proudly answer such
questions not sure
meanwhile we are kind of having a decent
position but still yeah that's the
problem with the philidor's like you get
what you want you have a dream position
and stay all kind of slightly more
exactly but it's it takes time to worsen
it so I'm taking it slow yeah nobody
seems to care about my raining anymore
yeah that's funny because I'd be ashamed
to answer this question drop below 2600
so that's terrible just that's a
showcase that we actually have a very
strong opponent because night of fact
I'm not sure if it's a strong move in
this position but it's an indication of
educated opponent yeah so that's how
you're supposed to crush this type of
position like black pieces stuck on the
queenside and then you go with 95 and
somehow I'm not sure how he's planning
to continue their time though and what
is the sign of the my g8 move my g8 is
the sign that your rock-solid night f8
to back it up yeah
loving it as long as we make sure that
the Bishop from b1 does not participate
we should be fine that was my idea
actually just to try to hold this
position yeah solve it solve it it's
kind of getting hotter and hotter though
to keep the [ __ ] won't be one it's like
you're more and more look at moves like
a takes or something that Quincy treats
it's a bit annoying yeah yes this night
some f5 is getting so wait he wants h4
h5 exactly yeah you want to keep the
bishop see to take actually we have a
terrible position will we do Russian
commentary for a grand final yes of
course like you will not get rid of us
that easy
Oh 9h four people will discuss what
laptop do B AB that's a labs laptop from
from the serious and those are not not
on laptops even though I do have a lean
way myself that's the dangerous part
that's edition but you should be saying
trade the Knights Knights are known to
be tricky pieces at trade the noise
maybe go of six questions yes but I was
thinking about this but not sure maybe
those are six
it's like f6 bring the Queen you know
the problem is just by pure spirit of
contradiction I will not do this okay
that's always so I should suggest bed
moves then so you'll be playing good yes
just do you know just to upset me yeah
that's cool it'd be nice if you were
waiting for a moment to ask something in
the chat that's a problem because
because I'm not looking at this no no I
do not accept any responsibility for
this one being miss played yeah this is
my day
yeah that's you okay precisely okay move
the King away please I wanted to please
move the King yeah yeah well make a
different move as the King okay I was
suggesting movies they can move the King
for two different square
basically we're looking like a couple
who has been married for 20 years and
that's how we would live you know that's
like he's the correct me seriously
seriously yes never play of six been
coin gold exactly exactly been thank you
but that's not not been Simon that's
been Feingold said but yeah thank you
thank you been anyway thanks the
Bensimon obviously yeah de five is me
fine
yeah should have played of six yes but
what's wrong with like okay what's wrong
was the position I'm being scared that's
what's wrong now I will play the bishop
and if on e5 it's better move that's a
much better myth
voila I'm scary trade the Queen's I want
to always like queen of Savin like I
like annoy him with trading the Queen's
so are we going to win well we're going
to lose because I've suggested the
terrible myth okay no I can bail out
very nice saying I didn't say we have
seven I meant Queenie eight but I did
say enough said no yes I will
oh my god this is what the hell is going
on okay I'm still a little bit better
and I'm and down the porn yeah yeah whoa
that was intense
yes this was intense because I was
thinking about it wow the pay of the
second bishop yeah I know that like now
we should know was there was terrible of
me playing this queen of seven thing of
course as you say during commentary that
this is not your piece so you can't
sacrifice it but this is my piece okay
check
it's a check yes don't move your noise
yeah but the thing is like I'm trying
for this Mouse
okay now Mouse is the problem of course
then it would be glasses night is
hanging yes I saw it I saw it okay like
I'm trying to very hard to blunder
anything so I can leave you by yourself
yes but I have a huge like potential for
assuming someone's very kind yes okay I
want like well played GG okay let's go
let's go to the next time a little bit
scared oh I have to admit what's going
to follow Theater sweedler I think is
tearing all this hair in his hand I
think right now so he's trying to to see
like what the hell is going on okay just
what am I supposed to do three two let's
try three what you're supposed to click
just click yes except that I would like
again play the game no that's unfair
nobody's I okay
no no we play we play where's my plate
yeah I've been born to fight to fight
yes not but also to never first line
I've been raised to never resign I will
die in the chessboard okay where is my
opponent keep opening oh well in this
case sometimes people challenge and then
yeah we can like give the guy another 5
seconds yeah well the game has actually
started I think so shouldn't we kind of
alternate the French and we'll have this
Belgium joke which says like well as
long as you win you play okay if I may
ask for a movie funny 5 I know
Oh No
I told you okay what what does take only
four but then if I fight what is going
to finally someone's listening to me I
just know what am I supposed to do this
opening so maybe not not really
is it the moment you take only four
brilliant
whatever the wait wait wait no primera
lives in this studio yeah night if tree
and now you would ok the pre moves
adventures was reasonably strong would
be yes of course but it's it's like it's
the audience should choose do put each
other that's a funny situation yeah I
mean we made this we have no problems
trying I mean if as long as it's kind of
a reasonable you know reasonable
suggestion today it was a trap I wanted
to take about five what trap have six no
like six hopefully the six who really
don't position ok ok you're not supposed
to care I was like you make a lot of
moves that make sense just in some weird
order from time to time yes since the
first play well and then okay what did I
do that he's gonna castle wall yeah
please do I encourage you I dare you to
Casa Loma
no no no what
yes I just read an interesting article
by Vladimir Kramnik you know where he
was talking about playing the chess game
without castling at all and I've
analyzed some games played by alpha zero
and these games were just incredible
where neither white nor black would
Castle and it creates a very interesting
and complicated games I just still don't
understand why this game is still one
and should have won it like which one
this right yeah this one wanted like
billion million moves ago you would show
me for Bishop e4 for me okay
stop complaining by that point people
suggest to try to play a six b5 Bishop
d7 against efore mm which is which was
done once against Karpov right by Tony
miles
efore a six see a huge opening is that
the one well I'm not sure good right
that I mean there is a nice suggestion
if we can be 45 F for someone over this
like it's like a never ending game like
yeah because killing your to collide the
not to kill I don't want to kill someone
yeah you do typically what you do during
the Blitz game you attack the Poland
species at random and wait for him to
blunder like for instance here you have
Bishop nice story but it's like when I'm
playing blitz it's like I'm playing a
simultaneous exhibition against kids
it's it's such a nice feeling and I'm a
kid myself so I don't really care
okay okay
p2 you have the group on a faith which
doesn't do anything yeah well just to
remind you yes of course you wanted to
tell me that this is such a nice
hmm Luke g8 no g8 yeah okay the rook
which is my doing
yeah this is this is a nice room do you
want this to the thingis I wanted to
take veg for ba it's like illogical
woman I felt like this argument will pop
up and supposed to be illogical yeah the
problem is like like what do you even
say after this ha ha ha well the
argument that's how you win an argument
that's very easy
now take your H board you can have it
yes I can have it king what wait SEC f3g
for I know guys that that's not a
serious that's not the serious Josh how
on earth I'm like so well in time I
don't know this thing like what kind of
game is this
you're not long time you know 140th
what's the I don't know Knights tango
which is d4 Knight of 64 like yeah
that's actually a decent that's a decent
opening I would love to play this one
what's going on yeah we trade precisely
we trade Ruby no I mean just in case if
you want to play a strong therefore for
a change for a change and now well your
ponies go yes now you're trying to
protect it English pathetic system
what's between existing is it six no no
no in the English English opening Linux
system sir I suspected it's meant to be
the c4e for Knight c3 Knight GE to set
up this thing so when am I going to make
yeah if I if I ever not saw you on
Quincy for trade everything I got to
trade everything I want okay you're
hopeless
the luckly and gambit isn't I'm afraid
we won't be able to play all this stuff
black not Deemer d45 efore I'm afraid I
don't know the theory but it can be
tried yet can be tried say suggestion
for second Queen age 5 we are not as
good as Magnus Carlsen so e45 tweenage 5
is not happening on this okay guys
like it was right yeah the question who
was right I have a minute yeah this one
you can you can handle you see my
opponent offers a draw
no no it's such an elegant offer I I
admit but see the thing is like I have
too many queens on board soon of course
I can understand that it's it's a nice
try that's okay
so the games still go on I know we've
finally won so now seriously we do have
suggestions for openings Kings gambit
okay what else
Danny's gambit whatever it is d 4 D 5 e
4 that's another option black MIDI Mayer
or something and ok let's see what what
color I would have in the next game
yep I just remind you that 5:03 2 is
like our official time control for this
blitz game okay should we take like a
strong opponent okay
stroller Poland of course is like higher
rated I'm black again yes maybe you're
picking the challenges where people
specify that they want to play white
okay
Budapest gambit then kind of somewhat
weird suggestion to try Defour Knight of
6 C 4 B 5 and move to which is M hmm
kind of what what what's that
accellerated been co-op would call it
well I'll be replace or something kind
of diversify your play oh well that's
that's old news stories for exhibition
okay okay I didn't put my pawn and c5
yeah and as we said that's an English
stream but I think I've got some
questions in because there are people
asking in Russian if you will will be
commentating London yes we will done
with him coming here but London legend
I'd sub-sectors AFTRA mitrik Adam
Freeman a shallot post inclusive scope
with this DCT gives it to transit with
must clear me accursed a business today
with which decision [ __ ] are you not
dude watching insidious nip I didn't
catch the maximum I said a graphic
rights some Agnes on comm diagnosed
early much okay coming back to the story
Bishop e6 was once again I'll be like a
grumpy grumpy guy Bishop e6 was not the
point
why did purchase ok speak English oh
he's wearing me down you don't really
like I don't know what am I supposed to
do here huh whoa funny funny challenges
like suggestion for the finish like
checkmate was promoted night night I
mean I'm afraid it's like taking it too
far I think that statistically it is
very difficult to do so and yeah let's
kind of respect I mean first of all it's
kind of our opponent has to lie steal
checkmate then it's unnecessarily
dragging the game on you can actually
trade and go night of
for a change I'm suggesting like a
serious position and then maybe even
like really green juice I was thinking
about this like wolf Anderson you know
your change in Queensland ear and sounds
of funny in Russian well interestingly
in Russian in Russian yeah the man said
Dean leisure interestingly I would claim
that this is a closer this kind of a
close aversion to Chinese pronunciation
which is something in between yes like
English versions Russian version and
Russian seems to be kind of a gap but it
once again is crazy a really hard but
they think we should ask him like once
too still we would not be able to
imitate the way they okay because I will
like have a such a nice for post the
outpost do you mean before yes yes go
for it
efore and c4 so the forest is in English
outpost is socially okay
my g5 I'll be scared of some lights
enrolled yeah of course but the night
nights are always around that's the
problem
you wanted to there yeah yeah but this
was once again I will in fact I'm
thinking who thinks of tree was a like
really strongly but now we once again we
win more material it seems so far
I know we've blocked let's not me
absolutely when you blunder it's it's me
okay okay but night okay now I'm fine
no you are sort of fine yes if you win
with an extra night my external mmm-hmm
okay manage I'm not sure I'm not sure
okay
oh well actually now on a serious note
what has decent compensation I mean it's
perfect especially for a blitz game like
I'm such a greedy oh you like the fall
wasn't much better movie it would seem
it's like somewhat better for us I'm
thinking everybody's like only see a bow
and I think it's like a computer that 96
is what he wants yes but there is the
but now let's let's go Queen ursin like
let's go for win strange I mean you're
scared for our racing Tom Skerritt for a
king as long as the queen is on the
board it's always scary yes of course
as long as long as his Knight is on the
board I'm scared
no our Knight is king yes but that's
solid right doing there some material up
underneath this I mean why this game is
still on but I don't know
I'm too scared you shouldn't be yes
what's the problem I don't know wait
wait what do you take all of your pieces
of that group on e8 925 that that's all
and then you panic
yes exactly I don't know it was rope
with an extra rope oh I have an extern
yes and rookie four is a terrible
mystery the way even with an extra room
you have to work f1 year kind of you'll
be making panicky moves again I'm fine
yeah now okay seriously let's win the
winning positions because yes it's not
so easy to win the winning position and
especially I think that this this is not
very easy exercise to play Bunter blitz
is because I've played against fuchsia
you know their sponsor blitz it was very
difficult I was so happy to win one game
of course I was probably playing against
the strongest opponent in this
tournament there is still Magnus Carlsen
but he's so precise and he's so quick
that's at the end I was completely
scared I was not sure with 16 in this
match so it's still okay it's not so
easy to find the way we've organized the
pieces yes exactly so trade the Queen no
you cannot trade the Queenslander seven
freely I mean that that takes a special
talent to organize the pieces in such an
awkward way that even with the rook up
we are still struggling with a nice
trick there will be five knight of seven
charge that was the point but now we
yeah no no we are much better okay let's
go okay this is like a much stronger
opponent I think yes yes okay so we are
going to our next challenge it turns out
Ali resides the highest-rated play only
chess
oh he's like the higher player here is
well the request to play they are
lacking defense which is like I think
Mira will do this because he was playing
that I can defense when he was a kid and
I can tell you the reason why the reason
yeah the reason why you pick up I like
in defense which is like by no means is
the most logical choice because people
want to you to play different openings
as long as he gonna play this d6 okay
but they play the Sicilian you always
gonna get black pieces oh yeah we should
be fine okay I say this is the reason to
play they're lacking was cuz you know
coaches teach their kids you go efore
then they develop the knight on f3 then
you develop the Bishop to c4 and so on
and so on so that's very easy it's like
II for you come Knight f6 the poor kid
girls night of three because he was told
sir by his coach and then you've snuck
his poison he pulled on the second move
so the question is do I still play
tournament chess well I'm honestly
planning to but last time I did it was
here in st. Louis about the year ago and
believe me didn't they didn't go
properly he didn't go properly ieave I
mean if I phrase it correctly it can
sounds it can sound nice because and on
a distance of eight rounds I've scored
one point more than very strong Russian
Grandmaster Alex on the bottom but yeah
but in reality I ended up sharing lost
with him after losing maybe you should
cause yes
maybe well I'm always looking for a
tactical never ever take such rook in
the blades of course no and I'm being
like almost autists not never ever but I
would strongly I'm just you know kind of
strongly of course I would consider not
to take the room because you're already
winning
yeah
you're to bishops in the pool yeah be
inside to bishops and Poonam and then
you kind of give him some ideas like 95
here then my g4 and all of a sudden he's
threatening a checkmate I hope he is not
listening to our program but still okay
noise oh no but this one is this cannot
be because please give a check win in a
couple of okay okay but then it's you
know it will not last long but that
that's fine
okay you'll play more games okay that's
how it works okay you should be
checkmate in copper wheel I will try
uh yeah thanks for pronunciation tips
but it's it's really hard for me to
pronounce eloheem properly because yeah
that's kind of a Russian name I'm
pretending I pronounce it pronounce it
in English way too but still I cannot
get rid of you know we like it's like
all the challenges here ok next I'm
black like men what is going on like
okay this is zulan again I will try
that's getting boring it's like okay
next time I will play the Scandinavian
defense if it's okay well actually you
request to try fo b6 I can't try this
okay
93 as far as I know is not what we are
scared of d6
seriously not might be not Bishop before
okay no this of course is okay because
it's kind of a bullish slovsky's
Sicilian with by the way weird looking
Bishop d3 why do we play a six and not
35 because I like okay often argument be
honest for you guys a5 is that's another
way to go with nikon c6 and bowler
slovsky's yes we explained it also in
our commentary have been in a moment yet
oh snap take on d3 right bishops
elephant's are much stronger than horses
yes because we are yeah we are Russians
frame right we are allowed to talk about
the elephants and horses right
yes very loud we make it happen
Bishop before in the opening oh no no
it's like the guys in your chapter
asking I mean if Bishop before is it
kind of does seem better but I'm not
yeah probably it is more kind of more
critical move and not switching to
because for the
being a normal Sicilian if white would
have played Bishop e2 that's actually a
theoretical position from bulla Slav ski
line but do you think is sometimes in
blitz you just make quite quiet pre
moves and then you're just playing
another type of position I don't know
sumon there should be five yeah I mean a
King h8 really saves you from this from
this the funny part is she plays wrong
miss but she ends up having a better
position to die that's how I feel the
position you know the magical field is a
terrible Queen since it was of course
too naive yes but the thing is like I am
suggesting this native moves you know
and like my opponent is materializing my
thoughts and then gosh think of Sicilian
yes yeah there was an attempt to play I
have no idea why it's called colossal
because it's very sharp that's fine I
think the shortest yes it's a very sharp
opening so like never sharpen it what
does callosity can have to do with sharp
well it's a little weapon it's not so
little it's a freaking machine gun to me
yeah the sharp you would think of you
know sword or something but not the
machine gun but anyway yeah that was the
funny one of one of the funnier opening
names I have to say that like rather
than that okay okay what's like I've
done have you done something wrong with
my position what they think okay I think
I'm still fine Peter Svidler has
challenged us Oh No okay okay
liters around 20 minutes ago I've got I
haven't been accepting his childishness
oh no of course I would like it's an
honor for me to play against Peter I
when I will ever play against Peter I
like I would love to play against
picture do six
yes of course we take in retaking the we
are being sad of the Queen d6 Queen oh
my god wait wait wait let's come
straight rook F seven students still
kind of hold because Queen d8 would have
been too much one all of a sudden we are
in shock or maybe we need to find some
moves
we will have to make a few like really
precise Olivia and stop making fun of
people but we are not making fun of
anyone it's like I did I'm just dreaming
to play picture my fantasy my just
fantasy making fun of you first of all a
fourth but you still have that's how
it's been for ages
okay life or maybe a age well why would
you need oh maybe five is a safe square
or before is it it's a good square as
well yes it's a better square I think we
can load beat Peeta we can force him to
resign yeah that's you know that's we'll
say something about clubs rating we need
to pop up clubs rating and so on and
he's going to know how does it go in the
Russian some do know is that it will be
him so we did [ __ ] accreta
yeah of course you do that was a blend
you can yes I mean if you want to you
know kind of make not the best moves on
purpose you can oh my god you know just
have you seen such a categoric you know
such a cynical read the Queen's please
commentator okay
efore good enough trades I know you know
you know what to pray we won't abandon
all the open files in the position yes
precisely that's the way to go I'm
making the irrational moves irrational
moves in chess just is a very rational
game I have to say your f5 pawn is
hanging I saw it I saw it would not give
it okay
after another world this g3 was really
helpful was it though oh yeah Bishop c4
Bishop d3 that that's but then please
play age 72 from pin gauge 7 I mean show
some culture some respect what I have to
put that with during these commentaries
like I don't know
nah finally seems we are winning control
airplane you have one minute 40 seconds
your opponent not look if I'm please
don't like ugly lives they make nice
moves ACK English 7 had to be played
ages ago
I will now because he has the dark
square bishop so you want your King on
the light square that that's so logical
it would seem to be logical wow you
finally see if anything of course of
course honey
okay so where's Peter
oh yeah right
b1 right yes so a little information to
you guys
there'll be a tournament starting
tomorrow which is called London just
classic and it stands for Grantchester
2019 final so that's the standing of the
how many seven rounds something and four
players qualified to the final it will
be Carson against which calligraph if
I'm not mistaken and Dinkley round will
be playing against left Aronian there
will be yeah there'll be a elimination
format so to classical games if one one
if tight then a tie-break on day three
so tomorrow will be classical time
control and it starts ten minutes to ten
the show starts or ten o'clock local
time here in st. Louis 10:00 in the
morning it's ten minutes to 4:00 in
London where the games are played like
what Peter is rating here like 15 so
you're looking for Peters except some
but I am accepting challenges you should
okay
gia moose yeah he's the one yeah so
officially we are doing it live we are
playing Peter Swift oh okay okay
Oh white you're white all of a sudden
sir Kings gambit it has to be no no but
there was a request to Papeete this
widow but at the same time and even
before there it wasn't request to play
the Kings gambit so we have to obey
yeah okay how are you playing the Queens
gambit doctor if he is not playing well
he won't play d4 he won't do such things
to us I mean he's a nice guy but are we
able to beat them to beat him together
what do you think what do you mean like
three games we'll hear no see five that
that's unfair that's unfair
9:36 now come on Peter stop stop playing
selling this Peter show your pretty eyes
come on we should be fine what is
happening now should have come for the
Sicilian think I never played the
Sicilian in his life we would crush him
we are trying I'm trying
no but this wine he plays himself on me
that's the problem a CD for Queen before
I mean I'm not sure of this exact
position but he does does play yeah
still we are doing okay yeah well I'm
and what do we do let's combine all the
challenges so let's wait for him to
Castle I mean I suspect he's hustling
short side and we will will Castle
alongside this one we yeah we take of
course we take do because some do
depends depends on the position if he
takes King thanks King d7 that I would
promise me we are costing no because
alluring it's not boring it's actually
like very interesting to play for white
and for black I think there was a very
interesting game very of Kasparov in
this variation which Gary Kasparov won
convincingly but he's gmos I suspect
it's a good friend Peter
what was the best square here was there
a best well normally they play they play
Queen c7 in this position so I suspect
you should not allow Quincy four okay so
that's like a logical deduction because
I do not remember anything so point
being before if you are supposed to win
somehow with Quincy but do you win there
I'm not sure if you look okay let's
calculate it so be 526 he goes to be a
95 mmm then we can like the five you
guess we should be seven we have a
perpetual which is a huge achiever oh
yeah against beat this with a huge
strike yes like we are threatening or
the perpetual okay to be 96 and then I
would probably go Quincy 3 this is how
it goes
also you mean you force his night on d6
which is a kind of a good square but
maybe like I don't think it works for us
yeah rook c8 comes too quick
yes but I wanted to take on e5 in case
Peter wouldn't notice and then okay
should have gone Queenie to them from
the beginning yeah but then like there
was Bishop g4 I was not sure he Queen c7
yeah three capito
do we play d5 no no no wait wait a
ticket do we have this time for this
maneuver which one do this
but why okay I mean this one I really
I'm really not the kind of an expertise
yes but they're like like if you have
time for this maneuver in this position
then you usually yes usually it's nice
then sometimes like even sacrifice the
pawn on d5 but like I'm not sure if it's
working here or not
so maybe we have the a5 from g5 yes oh
peter is going for four f5 which is
understandable that's why now it's
different no no no our position is bad
yeah no no because we have 95 now the
intermediate node and then yeah and then
he takes and then he's threatening both
Queen c2 and Knight f6 what do we do
about that what do we do about this I
don't think it's too late to think no
okay we're actually doing fine
well the problem being not c5 of this no
no offered wrong I'm being serious
that's a lost chance okay I guess before
yes
the queen is not yet getting trapped I
mean well what's the point fighting
against Peter I mean it that's like
that's a ridiculous idea he's gonna look
trick us anyway of course he's going to
trick insist that's what I was thinking
but still yeah 93 but then Bishop g5
okay Bishop g5 then we are sad yes like
the five though yeah
95 queen f - yeah we really resolved if
fine maybe I mean it's like you have to
play random moves in and hope it works
of course right I will try you try our
best
can we take try our best here Queenie
tree plate we need three pizza Oh No
Bishop each oh he's being nice not so
nice though sacrifice what's what's
wrong is putting the King on but you'll
play g3 anyway and you what's running to
notice to Bridget
okay do what you do I mean by that point
the position is already good enough
because you're played at four play
something okay
play something can I find the right
button
I don't know where's the like here's
such a nice night or where does it yeah
yeah for a change I'll answer a question
where Peters nickname comes from its
from Fawlty Towers and the character
named naughty moose if I'm not mistaken
well I don't know
yeah that's an unpleasant position if
I've ever seen one
the button on the right bottom right is
not the flag the flag is you know just
during your handshake yeah press it
press it I mean just in case press it
may be kill except I mean he's a nice
guy
of course he's a nice guy no he doesn't
seem to be yeah opposition though not
that it's particularly inspiring no
doesn't look like it
we're fighting trying to monitor the
chat what's what's the yeah it's 5-1
yeah hi big guys it's it's 5 1 it's not
5
it used to be perfect score against the
people have to say yeah it was before
the people became Peter Svidler he's
particularly awkward with two rooks
against the clean you think says I know
for sure how am I like transforming this
position into something I don't know
[Music]
scums I can control the motion of with
the whites 3 min o te [ __ ] iii+ to
be able to administer I'm Sur he
gradually control you mean I'm like
night the group d5 there is 93 and
that's precisely the moment you start
calculating lonesome certainly a
critical position in the game of course
it is I'm in fake on d6 whatever
whatever no but the thing is I
calculated the line and then my cavities
down at the end of this line
Karp of system with 786 would you
specify what what the system about the
cup of system is oh no oh no what
I've wondered press the hand the hand I
don't want to know you should Oh God
mm-hmm but like I'm low on time but why
would you play this position I mean if
like well I don't know whether you offer
a draw to ask if a friend is kind enough
or you resigned I mean I don't see the
point in playing this position now by
the way we are losing a queen as well so
that's that's really unfortunate
this one this one okay Peter Svidler I
don't know if it was Peter Svidler like
has won this game yeah I mean it's like
I'm talking to to the chat yeah for a
disaster full night English was bishops
yeah well fair point I should not be
criticizing al Meera I should try to
play myself like a bottom right buddy oh
boy no but that's that's resigned that
that was not offering a draw that was
resigning yes exactly that's what I was
trying to do to resign and but we were
just like making fun of our our our
secret plan was disclosure me that was
the whole setup with Peter and me in
Styria and then a Swiss beta was to pump
up Peter's rating on leeches yeah
someone got those coats yeah well on a
serious note now we'll make a short
technical break so those of you who are
rightfully claiming that I should stop
talking and try to play some chess
myself will actually see me in
well welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. chess
championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of fame cutting-edge exhibitions feature
rare historic chess artifacts paired
with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
and finally it's happening life mirror
we'll play some chess I mean I will
monitor the cat moaning Thor my play and
kind of make notes of all the stupid
terrible news I'll be making because
they'll be they'll be a lot yeah I hope
the paramedics are somewhere close yeah
but I'm a tricky guy so I thought we
always aim that you know gonna higher
rated people but there is a lot of fans
who are lower rated but still want to
play so always accepting challenges of
low rated people but very very important
please rated games that that's been the
policy of this show so we only play
rating games we want to pop up this
rating tool you know okay
so I'll start with I didn't know what
you know click randomly get black okay
it's it's my revenge now so you have to
shut up and play please I can talk a
little bit I have the black pieces again
nobody wants to play against me that's
healed serious the game is not story but
you accept it like I accept one of the I
was three plus two plus two okay so
what's three plus two we will try to
accept all the challenges that we have
like oh yeah online and there was a
request to play this move right okay so
now you can see the induction system
that's not the not my favorite g5 what
should i do at me well what do you want
to do 97 yeah I wanted a 97 but but
there are like 94 3/4 but my g7 is a
critic
: so you should always go to the
critical line all we always go okay for
the sharp line
gotcha then see five right yes that's
the trick blunder the pawn on d5 it's
not here to be taken yeah the 95 I don't
think it's a good move and of course I
would like to welcome everyone to our
chat you can ask questions in English
Russian French Romanian Serbian
I think Ukrainian we can cover it's a
little bit of Hebrew and boy German okay
let's stick to English Russian and
French for the moment Oh Miro yes
exactly this is the O'Meara show okay
then look my porn on define V is finally
taken and I'm still not scared for some
reason we will see all of our challenges
we are taking them randomly I think so
we will like because we have some our
supporters from the Russian chat as well
several trails will honor them wait a
sec somehow I mean I should probably say
a couple of words about the whole
opening thing because e 6 is of course
the critical move I mean white but the
moment white can play is 6 especially
after D 4 C 5 that's a critical myth and
taking on d5 is not a good idea now I
think I'm safely better to comes up at
Vietnam approach valishia kamizuru scary
deterministic net which is challenged in
accursed applets on as Pristina cranium
to the resistivity material is obliged
to party spirit luggage purchased
controlling applause really
prostitute amendment Kim and I'll say it
mention it in English as well so we do
not regrettably we do not have like a
cue procedures something Sates and I'm
once again I'm not able to you know to
pick really likes it so it's nice if you
mentioned something in chat like play me
play me but I can't promise to you know
to really play with everyone who is
asking me right now I was actually
expecting something else some messages
no some messages in French like but then
they were there saying don't show me
love come stir like I'll just so you
have admirers and Frances okay
now I can safely castle because my
opponents prefer not to okay let's be
honest I'm making North Dakota misc
this seems to be a good position for me
let's see how I'll mess it up
might be tough though by that point she
opens up he is king in sent a note my
king innocent I don't like making in the
center and my next move is very likely
gonna be II 65 what if it's a good move
Congress leader sheet or near kat aruba
did you come in here with you Jeannie
what is your next tournament to
compensative Gainey and so of course it
starts tomorrow we already mentioned it
but we would love to have you back of
course this would be for the Russian
auditory like but we have our English
fans especially when the English
transmission is down that's our hour of
glory guys from English for some reason
they mess up in this their stream is
down that then we have a fantastic
viewership of course they're like yeah
please remember this for the Russian
showed I suspect that the dipper
questions when I'll be live on English
she'll do the last run free drum free
Jerusalem said 11 December 11 yeah
December 11 is the first round so I'll
be I'll be covering this policy yes well
we're doing the crunches your finals and
then there will be the the last
tournament of the Grand Prix series
which will determinate who is going to
qualify for the candidates
why should mark and the Queen should
have preferred the other Cup show I'll
put it this way because Queen B 3 would
be I mean Black was winning but the
kingdom for a queen that one second that
went really well for me please
put on a fight against if again you
because we've like we've been to course
of course we've been playing some blitz
it's a sandwich chess club and okay he
was not very merciful in these games so
what do we do well obviously I'm taking
the game of them just like to be safe
I'm trying to play like there is one
challenge of 2546 can be yeah we will
probably lose I mean played by the looks
of it we will certainly lose 25:46 seems
to be like a very strong rating but
let's give it to you guys thank you for
your kind words and commentary of course
like like do the trash talk with the
beginning I just don't him only once I
will send the messages and then of
course I would like to salute everyone
in Moldova I was born in Moldova and I
still go there like every year and I can
see that we have also admires in Moldova
so France Moldova Russia America
everywhere yes so this higher-rated guy
luckily for me seemingly is not so scary
so I am aborting the game happily
considered itself as a you know as the
victory and we move on so are you going
to be doing commentary alone and for the
Jews like
yeah well I know it's not the perfect
setup by by any means but that's how it
looks like Americans speak English
French Russian Romanian yes ever
creation I understand German and Italian
but the Cape I think that I should stick
to the languages I would easily read so
it would be English Russian French and
Romanian and curiously French be in my
first language
no because the question what do you do
against this b3 I would go if I yes okay
and 96 okay the other option would have
been g6 Knight f6 but then you expose
yourself to e4 okay okay this is the
horror show that's what I think so we're
not doing any of those we try to be safe
and quiet yeah doesn't speak reaches
sparkles violet so we speak like a lot
of languages together so I think I think
that we can do the survivor show
together I think like they they could
stroll what's the I don't know or
something like the mix they would put up
look as in a situation where we would
have to survive what the Butte Indian
environment what the beautiful Kings
Indian I'm getting there by the way with
yes somewhat strangely placed this this
guy on f7 is but not reasonably happy
with my position I see what research
does after this mobile team for those
that come in zero it's now Rose come in
misciagna roskov Okinawa much in Rada
nice data key might system leaders truth
now that capita Prague knows the English
Narayana
Magnus British Maxima Magnus knickers
nobility leadership such as estimate a
degree not a break a budget Gretna
period of Cossacks capita O'Meara is
very old older than me okay okay
no no that would seem like an barrel
because I'm not wise at all better kick
let's not forget we are playing chess
here and I played a very very dangerous
move g65 luckily I have night h6 yeah
dr. Taurus would be happy with this myth
to back it up it's actually not such an
ugly move as it seems because now after
gasps oh yes of course
so honestly I believe Whitehead to play
h6 yes quite Center played six because
now I'm kind of getting a very very
solid position it would seem cool cuz
after Tanya energy nights epimysium then
to seven Moscow time yeah precisely what
do I do here I would cuss oh yes you go
yeah you do not care about the dish of
course this one g7 it's a powerful piece
even in this structure but yeah but what
does reasonably well with it I think it
weren't goofily would like I would not
like our decision here is good food
anyway you like yeah but look now we are
blessed by our opponents not taking our
bishops I wait a second I should stop
talking stupid things because it
actually is getting Portuguese would be
difficult it is actually is getting a
bit annoying so I am afraid I will have
to do the King
the Indian thing Wow I was considering
you have tree to be honest like f3 and
when when and if he takes was the bit
now that that that's just silly right
and no longer happy with my position
Bishop Peter was a brilliant decision
but by our opponent but you had this
very strange move did you consider
Quincy seven five is not terribly bad
about Queen d7 G four and then I think
that c5 is not terribly bad well he's
just he just doesn't want to agree with
me
but thanks for the suggestion I'll do
you Louise
I mean my whole point was that I kind of
praise the guy for there should be two
Bishop g4 and went 95 so if he girls
Bishop g4 I'm taking till ninety three
yes this I know they say no the most
important idea was that white wouldn't
be able to trade the white square
bishops kind of mildly annoying a bishop
is not ideal I have to say our Bishop on
on h6 is not ideal
yeah that's one that's what I'm looking
for I think that's why I'm here
me to make good news okay I thought that
was responsible for good may have seen
this in this oh now that the pieces are
yours the squares yeah cuz no those are
my pieces are no wait this room belongs
to a six right now g4 I think he still
has a cage for you you might actually
sacrifice think change I didn't like
this okay
G for like keeping it solid right but no
the guy's gonna run away with Miss
Castle right
no no no no I don't have enough patience
now we definitely go G for which yes
that was so stupid I mean no G for we
have to go after II know but you would
go if three no of course yeah but if you
would have played that three would be
left with this idiot on H 6 for ages no
we are slightly better I then got lucky
no that was really it was a strange game
because like can we can we analyze this
somehow
should we not really I mean I'm just
clicking buttons I shouldn't be doing
this
so next game right yes next game
are we having white and one of those
games so we only had white against
bitter yes that's the only game Google
ah but let me see mister in an algorithm
which gives you white when you're
playing against a stronger player and
which gives you a black when you're
playing it supposed to be random
oh that's why we have white in this game
okay as people requested so we wait for
e 75 so we are going to play hope
then we'll play the King's gambit even
though it's not the great opening seems
doesn't work okay let's give another 10
seconds but yeah but it doesn't seem to
work this one yeah it appears to be that
only like few most recent changes or
challenges are active for me that that's
the that's regrettably the case yeah
perhaps we will have to certainly we'll
have to abort this one even though we
have a lot of games with blackened yeah
big figure why can't I pick the one
being the one for me how many chose but
he has more challenges how many
challenges let me let me show you how
many that's a casual game we were not
supposed to play okay so guys please
offer us rated challenges and now we
have efore against us in the casual game
which I'm not sure okay I mean since
we've started in fact I might as well do
it and I promise to play Knight of 6 but
I did well negative 695 she wanted to
pose no no Knight of 6 and everyone
oh wait to arrogate know where the queen
is going who can tell me
moto G 5 not to sister let's just
recreate fight for everything
85 OD 6 or da concrete principle
challenges very sticking to against
nighter 6 so you'll teach me yeah of
course like ok
you could lose a queen ok this is 66 I
don't know keep this one yes for the
moment you could play actually Bishop
two for it
but let's see what I can do my thing
okay just no longer well no longer
proper Scandinavian turd
I think like by putting in fact like d3
Bishop d2 makes a lot of sense it's just
that you are supposed to fianchetto the
bishop then put it on g2 and then rugby
one before that that's a legit plan for
why it's like no this is of course it's
this position especially after e3 Bishop
d2 normally you you're trying to play
more aggressive and play with a long
castle in this I thought this one exists
as well will be one with the idea to
push before yeah and here but yeah but
Bishop Oh need to somehow is not okay
with all this general talking what move
are we playing and why can we play e5
because we don't want to we have a
beautiful Bishop on g7 yes we'll have it
in every game as long as I'm allowed to
develop the pieces we will have it in
every day and then on g3 as well well
shall we blunder this e5 pawn somehow No
we cannot okay let me see it's actually
getting somewhat annoying that it is
pressure and did Peter lose the game no
she didn't
so far the only game well in fact we can
say that the play the people team is
100% still because the only game chess
club was the game against Peter Svidler
am I to move again I mean what what
what's going on what I always have to
make ms that's that's getting on me so
there should be seven in fact yeah it
might seem to be like a sort of a defect
or structure right the fact that I have
played ef6 but I'm guessing white
doesn't have like a lot of it doesn't
have enough space for all the pieces
outlay repay da yeah at some point I'll
be looking at my d4 so in fact I believe
black is like maybe already it's a tiny
bit more pleasant has already tiny bit
more pleasant position okay guys we will
try to Warner all the challenges and
maybe for our next game we will try to
play you know that's a catch I would
tell you which piece to play and then
you would okay not sure like you should
prove an existence of a brain first and
I should prove it yeah well you see
insults yeah that's what we do it I've
never that's a hypothesis you have to
have never stated that they have one
well actually an ID to Bishop of three
is nicely played by our opponents yeah
because he needed to regroup his pieces
69 yeah come to G Ford and it would be
really probably doing okay steel but not
super happy but what hasn't done
anything wrong so like his position is
very sorry how did a game against us
this is the moment he went through
deserves to be punished
well at least we're attempt now the
serious question is v5 which I'm not a
big fan of first place sir does it have
to be b5 now I'm probably going ideal or
it's it's like it's really hard of
course really hard to not apply this but
you have to be quicker though I think
yeah one Sardinia just stop talking yeah
and something which is like a real
challenge for Mira to stop Tommy and I'm
not sure if it's doing his sleep but
it's it's supposable have some increment
though yeah we do I think we're playing
let's try to attack d3 if it's weak
oh yes like like you are attacking the
dis video I'm sure that you're aiming on
g2 but it's not like I'm getting the
play of tree yeah it's just like
pretending we have some threats here if
threat is much more important than the
execution is you know so C is play
mystery now we have to take care of what
Queen c7 is what yes kind of makes sense
I mean sometimes some mighty tree will
pop up and also d4 for some reason I
thought d4 is impossible the Queen on c2
is protected so in fact d4 is opposed
and you would have this terrible and
game I think yeah oh so I take no he
takes yeah terrible for whom for your
opponent for my opponent so B means good
okay yeah whatever it is yeah whenever
needs a day it's a nun game I would feel
like put the knight on d5 facing for
I will have to think of it because I
wanna win a porn that's silly right
that's what I do okay let me take after
all it's my game
that's a terrible yes but as you want to
contradict your you are almost forced to
do this I know oh my god the time
trouble me reasons I trouble you so is
my opponent it
this one is a brilliant bit yeah king of
one I mean I was hoping to trap this
light well okay five rook c8 would have
been like a picturesque possession by a
denied on situ had zero moves and like
that are now it's not how you do it
should have gone kingi to right yeah no
yes I agree the night is kind of getting
a bit well is it a lot stock then I'll
be able to stop just stop talking and
try to convert and I'm not very good at
it what language is spoken in Moldova
it's a Romanian before it was Russian
because it was part of the Soviet Union
but now Romanian is the official
language and of course Warrant Officer
no I don't think it's a proper momento
for a Jew black is better
I mean seriously better peace up
now finally I have a position that I can
can convert my way I make sure that all
the good moves applied and not a single
bad move so like this for instance I'm
not sure if it's a good move actually
but Mira's approach is kind of pretty
chassis now shall we give him a chance
for a stalemate so the king is not
moving as you can see so there is
potential for some you know desperado
regrettably for our opponent there is
upon only two which can move otherwise
it would be terribly awkward that he
would you know get rid of his pieces
with checks and his king would be
stalemated but being as it is now Luke
c2 we take with the rib he still has the
a pawn rookie to will be a checkmate are
we playing heaven tails you want to be
the brain the brain as much as you want
to object to everything I say there you
will have to okay good okay
obey it has to be like three plus two
yeah we need something just see we need
something of course yeah okay like
scroll down a little bit so let's see
how how strong should I be our opponent
as possible of course okay then this
okay let's do this like okay just limits
it okay to nine nine
okay we are playing with white yes night
come on I hate porn okay okay this like
yeah you you never specified okay rook
rook okay okay rook I mean that was the
only move with the guys do not blame me
and and obviously that's that's not to
do though
a pound Paul is it supposed to be this
border just clear trolling going let me
tell you something okay actually it's
it's nothing easy exercise because we
all have our chain like of thought so
like this and I have no idea what mirror
is thinking and now I have to
concentrate on a thong like on a game as
well
Oh like you want to trade creams okay he
wants to have a forced move so Knight
also know you might be getting less
terrible position that we I don't know
of course I don't know which Bishop at
first pretend that everything goes
according to plan
okay should we cut some yes we should
castle you say King thank you the castle
is like clear of an indicate didn't know
that I would consider any other move in
this like it's my I'm a I'm a hand and
tails are okey you okay something okay
what should we do here mmm-hmm that's
the only point yeah yeah but it's not a
bad position from reopening it would see
so we are having some hybrid from
killed' or Italian or whatsoever I think
so no what do you think I'm not suppose
bishop but why there okay it worked
cream I hope that you enjoy it as much
as we do
that's the point yeah we have to enjoy
it yeah well I think it's so obvious
okay I hope that I will win like my
first challenge so far we are doing good
we're fine
yeah and that's that's a very very silly
opening obviously Knight c3 Ruby one
before and it's not for I mean II don't
do it at home like we would but at the
same time he was it's like it's not
accidentally this opening was played
because I told the mirror once I had an
account in one of the plane service when
the goal was like to reach a decent L
log by only playing 93 Ruby one like to
first moves nothing can stop you and
then if you kind of if you do not lose
the Knights if it's not 90 25 will be
1.d4 then you're you were supposed to go
before a mystery so it's basically
playing well actually
will you please because I've already
cheated once I've already made a move
which was no I said fun yeah as usual
like working like old couples do you
know they fight and most couples are so
poisonous we are commentators Brooke
okay thank you very much
and I hope that we will be doing
commentary for years thing is it's good
it gets really tricky when we are like
on one minute or something because it's
like you know double pressure for you to
name the piece and then for me figure
out what what on earth she meant okay
let's say Bishop hey improve your pieces
you should always improve like Bishop on
g3 is completely stupid I would say was
a great Bishop I liked it yeah yeah
babbu night seriously not sure if it was
the movement yeah this one
I would like to see some defense first
and then we'll decide working yes of
course okay okay
rook rook serious rook yeah okay look
yeah why not
it's a nice move is it yeah did you say
so
our move again I will move again inch
for night all stopped rolling yeah III
was ridiculous of course but it doesn't
matter
Quinn
for a minute I mean I don't know what
that's where the Queen's supposed to go
whatever you like that's like we made
all the active names now everything's
gonna go back yeah that heads that's how
we play chess yeah yeah but like yeah
let's team up okay okay now we have very
long time I think for this exercise so
we have a very comfortable position now
it's probably not so great anymore not
happy with what I would have said porn
um but I would play this even though
it's probably okay
hmm look I don't want to give it we
probably should have by that point
because now we will be surprised
I wanted to devil on the file think of
something else
Mira what's the play
Oh Mira
right
Bishop oh no all right I'm sorry okay I
have to be fine really
what is like I thought we just just get
rid of this and then please but wait
this phone we could read and think a
piece if you say so of course what's so
scary now that this doesn't work I hope
this should work I mean not the position
but the the game itself
no we're crashing into a question is we
have we need life yeah or YouTube okay
live on YouTube fun form as quick as
possible
ah we have 54 seconds
Bishop Knight problem is I'm not good
enough with this crook yes actually
makes our life easier the fact that
we've lost in exchange rather why won't
the bishop well Quincy - wasn't bad but
Green Knight good night
one office is fine I mean I I was asked
by our producers that he if we need a
new master it's me I mean you need to
you need the other guy to play chess
because Mouse is fine it's not very good
but I hope that we're better at
entertaining you at home
like I think it's with them is it now in
Europe like me so I hope that we are
making it more enjoyable and I was
looking at some challenges as well so
let's see let's see okay I'm trying to
accept the challenge no Kings gambit
this time
no nothing nothing happens regret
nothing happens so let's try now let's
try the I don't know what they're doing
this is gonna sound very much maybe oh
yeah
okay it works like that sorry and I also
cheated and I gotta quite pieces this
time but yeah really the point was like
you know not to drag it to what we are
supposed to do in this case if our
intention was to play the Kings gambit
and we omitted you can still play 93
here no wait for you just like no d6 +
f4 you can play this or I can do God or
I can do clever things a mere in Greek
means salty water actually I knew this
we are salty at times I mean no
sarcastic you know what do we do here I
mean we got this pawn to h5 it must be
for reasons we go age 6 and sacrifices
you know g4 first of course again those
fundamental principles always thought
those were overrated fundamental
principles of chess and who cares about
the center now but now I'm doing this
now I'm doing my thing h6 and then I
immediately start pushing the other
point right I immediately start pushing
the other pole how many how many porn
moves we played so far because I've
heard of something nobody takes it yeah
well just have you seen it at least yeah
yeah I would have gone 93 and 85 no
seriously I mean I know it's those are
not the best moves but it's like once
again I'm back to this memeing meaning
mold hello hello so he's 6 well actually
no he's gonna yeah they say 4 was
terrible
now he's gonna get the bishop before
being I won't be enjoying it all that
much but what can I do right so I do
this I
the Bishop b3 then yeah that's still
playable no seriously though II for g6
h4 you'd be surprised is not such a
terrible it's absurd the arguments I
think philosophically I think it's
absurd argument just because you had
that such a nice position let me ruin it
a little bit see it won't look so nice
and what sure what I'm supposed to do
not sure what I'm doing
certainly not the right thing yes guys
please join us for tomorrow's broadcast
we are doing a commentary in Russian but
I think that it would be perfectly easy
for you to follow this commentary and to
learn Russian at the same time so I I
would encourage you to stay with us
never thought we would go solo like
language courses please like tomorrow
I'm the Grand Chester final yet it's
called run chest or daughter if you were
wondering where to where to watch where
to find us
yeah now serious question because I know
what this guy wants he wants to
castlelong
so he basically kind of tries to mimic
us he waited for us to Castle short and
then he wants to castle the opposite
side that what we were doing with Peter
on the first part of play the people
that was one of the challenges like you
wait for your opponent to castle you
castle the opposite side so you really
think that he would Castle longer but
what do you do you got some short well
anyhow seems that we are having a great
position but it's not because of the
opening line yeah I do agree with a
mirror please note this he agreed with
me please note this one time one time
one single time
okay ration is hard to understand but
it's okay it's a language like Italian
you know the language of love
so please surprised what it is of course
it is it's very melodious period like so
many points have been written in Russian
so like and I'm doing my job as a
commentator I think I've like almost an
every show I've been telling a small
poem so I will continue okay as you as
you understand this show is not so much
about chess it is about in fact it's
like the problem is that you do not
understand it that was a low blow
yeah this is a low blow I'm not even
responding to this okay
yeah but seriously what's the but I've
played my games you're supposed to think
you were supposed to think here you're
not helping no I was helping you as much
as I could feel such point that we've
blundered at least right you do not want
to help me right Guinea Kaka let's
innovate semi-group Amish potato patch
of skin janowska the shittaka totally
gross Kenyan the cacao my mentor said
you're going at a poker
billion attack poker prakruti a virus
nope autonomous Chris really bomb and
the blue genius because I was
down acidophilus nephew collective
action yeah night before was unlucky
I believe the position already wasn't
kind of brilliant but this seems to be
it used to be you know guys like this
seem to agree with me the depression is
such a beautiful language so like okay
and chess is such a beautiful game
that's what no no question is should we
take kinesics
is there a proper checkmate in
transition you and you can see oh no I
want it's like to give create but then
give up holding with you let's give up
for all the material first and then
let's see what happens maybe somehow
magically gonna work for us now I mean
honestly 96 is the movie playing in this
position all day every day because it's
like simple it's clear you wait you want
to play well that yeah but it's like I'm
unhappy because it's like I'm
checkmating but yes some peculiar way
yeah and then oh you should have five
you know yeah or maybe even yeah yeah
I've calculated that father what I'm
trying to say once again the point like
you can see an easy way 96 you win the
Queen the game ends and you should
definitely go for this one because it
might be that there would be no
checkmate in this in this particular
case and the queen is always the queen
but it was it was a nice one for a
change there is a question how do I
compare shogi to chess for example I
didn't have that much of an experience
like in playing shogi but still I played
against some of the best shogi players
in the world but of course in shogi you
play these games with the handicap like
you so giving you yes give know like
most of the times you would you would
have two pieces you would be two pieces
up yes yes I wish I could you know
participate in some high profile events
with
and this could be one piece of could be
no.22 I think with my especially against
me that could sort of equalize the
strength but I really like the game and
especially like compared to chess and
sugar the endgame is a very sharp attack
you know mating attack and you pair
should the pieces on the board so when
you capture the pieces they become yours
and it's it's a very interesting element
because you have to calculate so much
more and sorry to interrupt I was told
that's a lost game and our opponent has
started with d2 d3 so what do we do
tango tango two to tango okay come on
come on how can it be our last game know
the what tango no we are not doing this
wait how do we refute this thing I don't
know but you know I like in this very
famous book by dr. Seuss like a cat's in
the head he says no no no you're not
supposed to do this when your mother is
not at home Oh No so I do not remember
the theory all of that but you mean
you'd be surprised guys and Knight h5 as
ridiculous as it looks it is kind of a
playable move was played by I mean in
Grandmaster practice and by the way in
this very position I'm not that scared
anymore because it's getting something I
mean as well I think that our producer
wants to have lunch otherwise we would
have stayed here the whole day no no no
mr. grandpa this is too much but I've
enjoyed the experience and I hope you
will be back to play against the people
yeah I have to say about this position
there's
f2f for deserves serious attention
before playing Nagi Juana
three note that opposition is brilliant
as it is but the other one is kind of
even more challenging f2f four would
have been really serious serious problem
for us and for those who are interested
in watching women's chest I will be
doing commentary for the last four
rounds during the women's Grand Prix in
Monaco so this would be some of the
decisive rounds as well and this would
be in English so you can join what side
do because all of them do we Castle at
all because so yes but we we will
struggle agree that's too much
we do have a very long and ambitious
plan they bring the King to bring the
King let's see how it yes let's see how
it goes when you first let our opponent
decide on what he wants to do with his
case reminds me these crazy computer
games I've watched you knows oh no the
games by jingler and you know these were
incredible games where he played can
give seven kings it King the Seven Kings
say it against Magnus this was such a
beautiful idea so the guy Castle blow
which kind of suggests that we typically
should be fine with counseling short but
we don't want them what our songs in
English about chess but there is a very
famous musical by ABBA so I think that
you should listen I think it wasn't like
number one on the charts
so please ask me some of your last
questions if you have questions for
mirror I was I also asked him not that
they care about his opinion but just I'm
very polite seems like it's now or never
because now whychus really it's got our
opponent is really kind of prepares to
look like you own castle here please see
for I felt like now whenever we have to
establish some sort of a come to play
because otherwise thank you
what do they say steamrollers that's the
word so who'd I think will win the grand
chest or well this is as I said it would
be very difficult to speculate
especially like the matches are so tough
I even thought this is like the
strongest four players tournament what
is they were tracing for this tournament
[Music]
just probably the strongest to my shame
I'm not really sure organized so and
then there is a question like okay if I
would be supporting someone during this
tournament the favorite was supports in
MVL or magma should have taken actually
destructed by Al Mira talking about
ratings where we supported my supporting
the resupport I knew and Magnus Maxime
ding man
rayvon it's like all of them are yeah
there are no bad guys in the tournament
like let's put it this way so it's
really hard to pick one all of them are
noise so let's say we drink for the
beauty of the game just movie actually I
liked French's movie which is called a
diagonal du feu but it's it's a very old
like relatively old movie but I would
advise the French actor Michel piccoli
is playing his role in an outstanding
manner so you would enjoy it I think I'm
trying to deal with what terrible
position did I enjoy the most we've
answered this during our Russian
broadcast I like very much help is
needed
haha well you're poking some stuff so
you see that via me you need me
yeah just admit that you need me and
then I will help you on your knees now
okay 9 questions all of the books
written by marked where it's carrying
our books are very entertaining and
meaningful and you can learn a lot I
also like this book written by
krzeminski and velu kitchen exercise
chest exercise book which helped me a
lot as well so I can say it's a terrible
position time sacrifice was a very
interesting movie I agree with you and
was it yes I did like it
Meera please answer the question what
should the King's Indian player play
against efore let him finish the game
and I will ask him that's not the
question is legit the position is
terrible I don't know I mean that guy
see that's the answer to your question
Meera do you play tournament game
I shouldn't be playing because whatever
I try it ends up being this terrible
thing I actually won't play by report
that much I can say
and actually we have a comment that our
show is simply the finest show that they
have ever seen so Mira Mira
would you spoke like I'm on 23 seconds
and you still know that I was waiting
for this move I mean I don't know how
I'm losing now but if I'm not losing
then I'm taking one of six very next
move okay I'm supposed to be lost the
feeling is like because I did like
literally everything wrong but but
that's what you always do I don't know
how I'm like getting rid of this
question mark once again because the
position still seems to be terrible if
we have an increment out there maybe we
can play one more game of course so we
should macoco music lfg community i
would shock matthias lee residents at
Levis mr. Roskam and this can be
commentary nishikawa's night yo Pamina
oh just to give a signal some tech is
some delicate instrument Lumina Francis
key yeah would you know the material
shock Martina Francis come to you oh
that's terrible
switches languages and position is that
terrible and I'm so of course it's my
fault cause it's your face it's my fault
position is there a bobbing never
distorting they're not doing anything
meaningful it's really terrible what I'm
doing but all of a sudden I want the
game even I said you know go crazy shock
mati if shocking with Nick I'm into oh
that was that was ridiculous what I do
still warm though we won though so it
should be play like one less game I
think there's
one can we when can we play the last
game we can't play last game but before
that yes we will have to announce the
thing yes we will have the Grantchester
final tomorrow starting from tomorrow we
will be doing commentary in Russian
there will be four players magnus
carlsen jingling Levon Aronian
and maxima Shirokov there will be two
classical games so each match will be
consisting of two classical games two
rabid games and four blades game yes yes
so in Magnus will be playing Maxime and
dink will play live on RNN so tomorrow
is the classical game number one please
don't forget that we are doing our
commentary in Russian but we just hope
that the english stream will go down and
then the pears for the semi-finals
ohh Karlsson against russia allograph
Dean leerin against live Aronian
tomorrow is the first classical game
yeah and I lied about the format and
finally you've corrected me sir doesn't
matter what happens if to classical
games one by one side this there will be
rapid you can win match like in rapid so
the bleeds will not be needed but you
cannot clinch the match even if you win
both classical games exactly so it will
be quite entertaining I think yes it'll
be like best place in the world playing
in all possible time controls you can't
ask for much more
lets me see there was a young guy who
wanted to play against us so just let's
do the canarians
yeah this is the worst business the
lecture and the question what King's
Indian player has to has to play against
against efore that's a tricky question
because that's well kind of pro-1 g6
seems to be obvious right
really yeah you probably you should
really look at the guys who were playing
the Kings Indian and look what they were
doing against efore because like one of
the examples which popped up right now
was gideros aina from azerbaijan I was
like wow we're a grand most of 2650
let's say he he's playing continuing
throughout his life and he does like a
dragon CC or something like that against
efore so I suspected it has to be some
sort of a Sicilian but not sure which
one yeah I can see the comments that I'm
like funny yes stand up is a passion of
mine like that I missed this looks like
we played to this guy already
no we didn't but they think yes maybe he
has been way to be with Peter and since
the game is not starring challenge let's
see not doing trio sorry
not doing trio yes okay do something
like five sir again three - three - no
no yes okay
Fievel we played was the black ghost I
think the key through all of these shows
and things like once again we played
four games of them no but choose another
it's just not to take yourself for
ourselves very seriously I think we all
love to play chess and like we all love
to make jokes so that's that's let's
play a decent decent game for a change
enough enough of this age five age oh
well we won't have a decent game our
poet is playing a gambit Knight f3 d 5b
four days what to do I suspect we have
to take and go from here but then I'm
really really not sure what to do
Knight f6 Bishop c4 living or what yeah
it's basically like a Buddha or whatever
it's called but the phase gap right is
us having the pawn on seven instead of
c5 which should be beneficial what kind
of Steel I'm so afraid of such people
who would sacrifice but kind of
sacrifice bones to me it's so scary I
don't know what to do so I even like
play age six or he's gonna take on him
seven eight yeah he felt this guy's
dangerous you see he's planning to take
on f7 well so I'll do this
I still blonde guys you still have like
your last five minutes of glory no the
thing is if he would have taken on f7 I
was taken back bishop g6 I would take
the bishop and when he takes my queen
there would be Bishop before check but
you know what what white is doing really
makes sense I suspect that we are in
trouble here what I'm doing on contrary
you are in trouble
please doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense so when do the matches start
actually yes we will actually we are
doing commentary in from the studio in
st. Louis so we will be starting I think
in the morning for like American time it
will be turned to time 10:00 to 10:00
central central time and for long then
it would be 10 to 4 3:50 p.m. and Moscow
Moscow plus 3 but the tricky fingers
like what time it would be ninja because
we have a lot of Indian friends here so
wait
central time here is has 11 how far
difference ok so let's say yes
so that that's like half an hour plus or
minus I mean guys there are around ten
o'clock inside I mean it won't piss much
mean 20 minutes give their well you're
pushing this too far what about
Australia guys you'll see the same game
tomorrow will be the same time for you
but just another thing just enjoy your
cup of coffee and I have to say I'm
doing reasonably well for the guy who
got born sacrifice at him and and got
terribly scared as early as men seems to
surprise you I'm doing reasonably well
yes I'm always surprised and I'm always
scared when I'm getting a good position
out of the opening because I am so years
to you know to struggle in the opening
and then kind of you know make my way
out of trouble by you know playing some
tricky moves but now that I'm having a
good position I'm actually a little bit
worried so now you understand that when
I was playing I were getting good
position that was the problem no but
like I was like two moves from meeting
him and I was still scared
I was terrified what could go wrong I
managed so now election you know once
again perhaps it could have been done
better than then I did but still
reasonably happy everything kind of
intact my king did not miss at some
point in this game I might be able to
cancel more which is not a bad thing in
the opening right sorry in the Indian
game I mean in the end game you either
won and keep your king like closer to
the center Oh Castle long is kind of
much more much more playable in the
ending right Nutini but show specific
facts here so if Danny has like
he has his this difficult quality he
cannot accept the compliment sir would
you like throw a lot of compliments on
him Sir please I would read he's kind of
shy of course it deserves all the
compliments I hope the Peter spotlight
is done and no longer watching a stream
rookie one is yeah it's it's kind of its
kind of not very not very lucky move
because now we are winning moment cereal
that's probably yeah that's that's a
tough position
but we will be back now with these
challenges we will try to promote our
YouTube channel so okay there was a
first try yes I really really enjoyed it
I mean you know mocking of me all the
time if the club gives us a chance
we certainly going to be back at this
one please know this mirror made the
compliment by himself this never happens
okay I think that this is just because
this is the last game and like with
always this pressure he cannot control
himself anymore otherwise it would never
have yeah cold-blooded guy you know what
I have to put up with for this two weeks
of work haha what oh yeah how what we
are a piece two pawns up and we are the
first site to give a check which is
advantageous of course the more checks
you give the better the position becomes
that was wise it has nothing to do with
good positions but yet but as I promised
never never gonna waste the chance to
cost something especially if it's like a
good move like it is in this position I
also wanted to mention that since we are
doing commentary from the United States
this was our first Thanksgiving for all
of us actually for Peter
Mira and myself and we enjoyed it very
much
well I finally have been introduced to
the turkey you know officially
introduced so now I think I hope that
it'll continue yes turkey likes me that
this tradition will continue okay
seriously though this game is
or whoa yeah this was our last game
pretty much
yeah
and thank you so much for watching our
show we are waiting for you tomorrow you
Guinea we just recommend that America
tripper Steve Romney Stephanie
commensurate naruse come and listen
chickens and radish ahmed next time so
it's possible
spasiba laughter must know we miss you
why do i keep concentrating in such a
winning position I don't really want to
kind of like you know miss a checkmate
in one yeah okay now you can check my
[Music]
brain brain or head oh just like lost
one last bit of you know not listening
to Al mirror because Bishop d7 of course
the check it was the checkmate but the
so was this one okay though beat yeah
that's very much for joining
apologies for those who were waiting and
didn't get their challenges accepted but
it's not easy for us as well we are
trying to one or all of these challenges
and I'm thinking we will be doing this
in the future as well this is just the
first time for you to like to get to
know us know and so we've been
officially introduced as well as for the
turkey that was away wait a sec so the
main point of this was to play the
people and once again to remind everyone
that London London tomorrow London
London final the Grantchester final
starts tomorrow second to eighth of
December there will be semi final and
the final matches for a lot of money
best chess players in the world all the
time controls Carson Bashir a graph Dean
mirin against Aronian are the
semi-finals once again we start with the
classical chess I believe the time
control is 2 hours 10 minutes till the
end of the game without this 14 moves
you know nonsense of course we
be able to cover a lot of topics during
the classical games and stay tuned with
it we'll see you tomorrow uh yeah thanks
so much guys I was so splasher and
hopefully see you next time that's after
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you